hey guys welcome back to big
mood look at who we have here today
beautiful
luxurious amazingly elegant
bomb ass looking nikki
i put in blaze for you guys today i
wanted to make sure dang
it yeah i wanted to make sure i showed
you looking good yeah i gave you all
them
inches she gave us a lot of inches all
them
inches and y'all didn't even ask for it
thank you yeah no oh my god i'm so happy
you're here because you know we've had
you on jk news but now we get to
have you all good to have you all to
ourselves i was waiting without those
stupid boys
you're always on a show with a bunch of
stupid boys oh
i don't think i've ever been on an
all-female
panel to come on here more often yeah
love to have you i've never been around
this much estrogen before
how does that make you feel happy is it
okay i was like is it more scary because
we had a
guest come on that we're not used to
being around a lot of girls and they
were
very nervous coming into like a set with
a group of girls they were like is it
gonna be awkward
were they male or female female yeah um
i get the intimidate like it is
intimidating
especially we i mean we've all hung out
before
yeah in different settings around a
bunch of other dudes yeah
so we've already had this different yeah
it's very different and i could see how
it could be intimidating
i mean we've talked about it um when it
comes to just like looks and being
around other women
and feeling secure but since i've
already been around you guys i know i
was like oh i can actually like get
dressed like
yeah and vibe and not feel like oh
they're gonna be like this [ __ ] really
showed up i was like yes how does she
think she i was like with all that hair
yes i was like first off i lost all of
my answers and you're gonna
bring them to me i was like we can
borrow it i will share
my hair with you it can come off
that's a true friend it actually
probably matches your hair more than
mine
it's like a ombre no it's more blonde
mine's like way pale my hair stylist is
going to be pissed she's like this [ __ ]
wore the wrong hair
it looks great thank you i feel like
yeah i don't know a lot about hair but
it looks really great thank you you look
pleasing to my eyes
every time she's on news i'm just like
oh my gosh you're just okay
your mouth and like the stuff that's in
your brain i'm like oh my god she's so
beautiful on the inside too i love
sitting next to her
it's like oh no keep don't compliment me
oh my goodness you care about what comes
out of my mouth and not what goes in
it yes let's talk about that okay
you like that segway i do that what goes
in your mouth on a normal basis
i know you were talking about um like
your dream
growing up like her dream job was to be
a food critic yeah
oh [ __ ] you're not far from it i'm not
far you could totally do it right now
working on it yeah what's your favorite
food like type of food
like from a food critic i hate that
question because it's like yeah
like what's your favorite color what's
your favorite food my favorite color is
blue
but like as someone that wants to be a
food critic i'm assuming you've tasted a
lot of food tasted a lot of food i
really like seafood so
all different types of seafood and i
think that's the
base because that's the one aspect that
is consistent but always very different
depending on what culture you're in
true and i like pasta but i don't know
as much about it
by default japanese all day sushi
every type i want it raw i want it alive
i want like
any way i can get it i want it with
japanese
okay we can hang out yeah we're gonna
eat together
over here i've been thinking about it
yeah i've been thinking
what's what's holding you back come to
the dark side
we got fish here i feel like i don't
have good quality fish around me
in la it's too hard are you in the bay
area i'm okay
more inland more inland yeah okay okay i
would be lying if i said i was in the
bay i'm technically not in the bay
and if you're from the bay you know the
difference you have to like specify it
you have to specify it i'm not in the
bay i'm um
technically what's the central valley
okay and then even in the bay area like
fish is still
scarce as far as getting good quality
fish and i need to learn how to almost
like they got a good aquarium so they
probably have
monterey does monterey which is is that
bay is that big
monterey bay equipment i mean the name
yeah
they got good seafood but i'm more of
like i get the oysters
and the clams love oysters what's your
favorite kind of oyster
oh my god
i like how i get it on her it's like i
love oysters
i tried what are the kumamotos
yeah i really like i really like those
but if i get a big
juicy a big old like you know
i don't even know the name of them but
the ones when you eat it yeah
on the grill that's the best
sounds amazing yeah all right well for
those of you that don't know nikki
she is a like previous mod or do you
still model
that's your your part of your resume
modeling but more importantly though
you're a radio
show host a morning talk show host yes
and i'm actually curious about that
career because
it seems to be like a really male
dominated industry so how did you like
what was your experience in that
well i came in already having like a
social media presence the modeling
background i had done
while in out and a couple other projects
so already getting into um
what people would consider like on the
lower side of media they consider like
radio on the lower side as far as right
on as far as entertainment goes you know
what i'm saying a lot of people
start in radio and then work their way
up i kind of was like i'll go down
like but i mean but that's how a lot of
people see it
like a big fish in a small pond there
not i wouldn't
say it that way because there are so
many professionals in that industry
and when it comes to that field i was
nowhere
near a big fish like it was more of the
wrong fish in the wrong tank
that's what it felt like it was almost
like it was like a fighter fish in a
tank full of goldfish like how we're
still on seafood
yeah sorry nemo
but it just felt um awkward
initially and it wasn't more of
being a woman in that industry it was
more of being younger and then coming
from a different industry
yeah yeah there's a lot of women that
are in um
radio and then there's a lot of older
men uh
people work very hard to get into the
position that i fell into
so i know for me i can't take that for
granted like i can't at
all say i was a big fish and i came down
it was i earned my spot
but i got fast-tracked because of the
other work that i've done
and the men are it's it's it's mainly an
age thing i think that age was more of a
problem than um
than gender i relate to that for sure
before youtube i was in the hospital
industry and in my my department it was
predominantly
ran by women but they were all way older
than me and there was like this
political thing that was really weird
where it's like
you don't know anything like you just
you i don't know it's just zero respect
so i get it
i got in trouble for dress code working
in radio oh
wow yeah what it's very like traditional
i didn't know because i worked at an
urban hip-hop station or a rhythmic
station yeah
and i worked the morning shift so i'm
like okay well if i gotta wake up and
i'm pretty much coming to my workout
clothes and it's just
me and uh my other host lucas which i
love by the way
um why did it matter but the women in
sales didn't like my attire
and then there were there would be a lot
there was a lot of other comments and
they were significantly older
and just the area didn't make sense for
what i was wearing of course not but i
had such a different mindset as far as
everybody's confidence levels being
different yeah and realizing that
okay i guess there's a dress code but i
still didn't
i still didn't quite understand it my
co-host was great
the men in that industry were were cool
it's more of the guests that were
oh you know a lot of there was a lot of
rappers there's a lot of singers
and everybody turns the corner when
they're coming into the studio and then
they're like
oh i wasn't expecting this on today's
media tour and they
kind of don't know how to act until you
throw out the cool card and then they're
like oh she's not interested she doesn't
want me at all
damn okay i'll stop now but for the
moment thirsty
yeah oh yeah because they're just used
to it like everyone
mostly after that well most of the
people like i said it's an age thing so
most of the people
early morning shifts are are a lot older
and
think about the people that were popping
back in the day these are jobs that you
keep for a lifetime like a lot of your
favorite morning show people
have been there most of your life so
you've grew up with them
and they're so amazing at their jobs
when you see a new face on a media run
you're like what
like this i had
i wore no makeup and started wearing
hoodies and it still didn't still didn't
stop damn
you can't hide that but it is a
compliment
i will take all of them until they don't
come no more
[ __ ] yeah no i kind of get the age thing
too even in
youtube because i feel like youtube
years go by so much faster they're like
dog years
where like the og youtubers we started
like 13 years ago and the landscape
changed so much that i don't understand
the new job now it's the opposite
now it's the newer people being like oh
you're too old yeah exactly
that's what i'm saying i am the older
it's like
wait is that how i was supposed to dress
like wait that's how long i'm supposed
to do my content
you think you're you think you're old
until you're around older people
until around younger people no you think
like when you're around younger people
of course we feel older yeah but then
when you're around older people they'll
look at you and they're like you're
delusional don't think that
you're i'm reminded so quickly that i
was like oh i may be like 31 but i'm
young as [ __ ] i gotta join your industry
though yeah
you'll come in i feel ancient already i
think i'm young until i meet who's
relevant and then i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm
so old to me that's so crazy on the
other podcast we
you know because talking about youtube
and the guys have been
you know you guys have all been in the
youtube space for a long time for me
i haven't been in that world so when i
come around certain people that are
older than me that like are
terrified of discussing their age uh
worrying that they're gonna like lose
lose um viewers or people
liking them or followers or something i
think that is
it's terrible because being in between
like
31 is lit i would not go back to 21.
seriously one is amazing people think
we're making it up and i thought
i will admit when i was 21 i thought all
the 30 year olds were making it up i was
like you're just [ __ ] you're saying
that because you're old
you want to feel better about yourself
it is true
i feel like i look better i feel better
10 years ago i look whack is [ __ ] i look
like a door
you could go to a bar and order whatever
fancy drink you want
all the experience you don't have to
wait for somebody else to buy you a
drink i think that's like
when you start going out you're
realizing like how much you don't need
other people
and that can come that can come like in
different
ages yeah but it's that independence i
remember being
terrified at 27. yeah 27 was a scarier
27 28
because that's when it started to feel
like what am i doing with my life
and then after 30 it started
coming together more than i realized and
then this last year was the biggest
reality check ever
and i think everybody had to experience
it no matter how old you were yeah
if you don't get your [ __ ] together now
you you are going to be left
so 31 was a great year transition year i
love it oh that's great and then also
because you were
you had mentioned before that you also
got out of a relationship this year too
right it was
like last year yeah technically yeah it
time goes by so fast i can't even keep
up
yeah do you feel like you've like that
was a positive experience for you like
because
usually a lot of breakups or you know
changes in your own personal life in the
moment you can see it as like oh no why
did this happen or whatever it is
especially if it you didn't call for it
and then how how
have you experienced now post post
relationship yeah because i see you
thriving girl thank you
thank you well the relationship part i
really kept on the down low i didn't
really
that was a that's also a major part of
the issue in the relationship
because discussing my relationship was
something that i didn't really want to
do because i felt like that person isn't
in this world
and whether it's good or whether it's
bad there's always repercussions to
talking about your relationship on on a
public forum so
um since we since we broke up
it's been better in the sense of not the
guilt associated with
why don't i do this or why don't i post
that and i know my faults in the
relationship and there became a point to
where
you have to look in the mirror and
acknowledge where you can't give
somebody something
and i think that's the biggest takeaway
is being able to own what i
cannot offer or what i don't even want
to
try and offer and if i was to go down
like the relationship road or like that
particular road again
the conversation would be completely
different first off career-wise
my priorities are different i'm not as
we were fighting over
what i think is stupid is the memes that
he was posting
and and like and going and following
people that i know that you've never met
and like stalking other like other girls
pages and
feeling so you're in this business but
you felt like that
affected your relationship on him oh
yeah
because i feel like for me um i mean you
know joe was my ex
um i feel like i would not give a [ __ ]
like because i'm like oh i get it it's
just all a game this whole social media
thing's a game so it's like
seeing who he follows or whatever this
or that like it means less to me now
than it did
before i came to the youtube space when
i was just a regular person
that wouldn't think you would feel
differently if the it was flipped
the person i was with is regular yeah
and he would do certain things to
grab other people's attention and
because he would do the same thing to me
so he's not worthless to him so that's
right right
so he was there there was a weight in
his actions
so it's not yeah so he would purposely
go and follow certain people
or we had an issue with a particular
person
and next thing you know i was you could
piece together because this behavior was
so repetitive
that i was like okay you just followed
someone new it's a pattern
okay you just posted something real
suspect okay i just go looked at this
girl's page she posted the same thing oh
next thing you know that's who you were
messing around with so yeah
for me he's not smart about covering his
tracks but for me that's why it was an
issue that was an interesting thing he
wasn't
yeah that was like people that aren't in
the industry do treat it way differently
we do i get that yeah so he would do
and it was like have you ever seen
somebody post memes and look and
and feel like you look at them
differently because that's a little bit
of what they're thinking
yeah okay a lot of it was very i hope
not because i post some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
just for
your shit's funny just for joking so
you're talking about being a massive
[ __ ]
and all this no no no that's like but a
lot of it for me was talking about other
women and like [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] and
they look like this
and girls sucking dick and all this
stuff and i'm going like this and i'm
going
oh i'm so glad nobody knows i'm dating
you because i was in
i became very embarrassed internalizing
that and then i'm taking it personally
and then he's like no it's not about you
but then you do certain things and you
post things forward
it's about women though and i am and i'm
not i am women
and i love your mom so there would be
there was a lot of conflicting things
social media wise but
leaving the relation like leaving that
relationship and it wasn't on the best
terms and
still in a very like you know in a weird
space because we shared
a lot of a lot of time together um so
i also realized i had to back away
because that's who that person wants to
be
and really at the end of the day like
you said should i should i care as much
about what they're doing online if
that's what you want to do
i can make it my own um issue to step
away from it i can be like hey i don't
like this i don't want to deal with this
well if there were some patterns and he
was actually messed up i mean then yeah
that's very
valid man i put two whoo [ __ ] i may not
be the best at math but two plus two
equals four
and it kept equaling four and i was like
why don't you subs
how about you subtract a couple things
and then he would and then it would
it's kind of it was very repetitive but
you know stepping out of the
relationship and stepping
back from it i realize what i don't like
and
for me i don't think i could be with
somebody that is very um
that outspoken on social media but
doesn't want to own it
i i you know what i mean yeah so he was
just trying to do it for
like to look at the attention um that's
too bad which is yeah it's different but
everybody has their own struggles right
like his identity crisis is his identity
crisis true yeah
and that's not but yeah that's just
you're a mismatch and right where you
guys are
right different we're in different
places yeah that's what i learned in
this time
like the separation and over the past
year and getting older
it's like yo i don't have to keep trying
to make something work
if that's who you are as a person i
should be able to respect that and
either if i
can respect it we work on my issues and
then we grow together or
we have to walk away why are we gonna we
ain't getting any yeah we can't force
yeah like i love them don't get me wrong
and it's like one of my best friends but
yo
we are i will it takes me back to
someone i don't want to be
true you hit a certain point you can't
keep doing that someone's bringing out
the worst to you it's a sign
yeah yeah yeah for sure definitely have
you been dating
since that or have you been keeping it
to yourself i'm pretty much to myself
i'm like i don't
i got into a lot of arguments over
wanting to be secluded and isolated and
not really wanting to explore other
relationships with people
i kind of got called out like why don't
you want to spend time and why you said
that
someone that was interested in talking
to me oh that's why
yeah somebody wanted somebody that was
interested
but i was no man i'm a hot ass mess i
got too much stuff going on like i'm for
you for recognizing that and like
i want to work on myself that's great i
was going through that do i want a
family do i want to do i want to work
do i even like my job oh my god do i
want to wake up every morning and do
this do i
am i happy with what i look like do i
want to
live here do i want to live there
there's too many questions that i had to
answer myself and i wish more people
knew
that if you don't have a lot of those
questions answered you shouldn't
entangle your life with the whole other
person's
life yeah unless you want to be in that
person's life and that be your life
i feel like that's what a lot of people
do that's healthy though it's not oh
we're not saying it's healthy
i like to drink a lot of alcohol we know
it's not healthy but i'm still gonna do
it
because i like being [ __ ] up but no
you're completely right
and it shouldn't be a problem to step
away like because if you don't know
yourself then you don't know where to
put boundaries
and then you keep fighting and you keep
running into these [ __ ] which i
think a lot of people call
other you know women or men [ __ ] but
in reality you're just an [ __ ]
yeah and you don't want to recognize
that person you know
yeah like you saw it you were able to
deal with parts of it but you
ignored it ignore yeah and we all again
i think alcohol is such a great analogy
for it is because we like we enjoy it to
a certain extent but then
what are we going to do be mad at the
alcohol for getting you a hangover like
you know exactly what you're doing every
time you sip it yeah
water can be right there when you know
your limits you know like oh i gotta
stop at two
otherwise i'm gonna have a hangover or
whatever right
um but if that really comes from
experience
see a [ __ ] boy yeah after that my
feelings get hurt it's
cut off then it's like okay now i know
why
i'm here then you can be a little bit
more honest about like
we know why what am i really doing
because sometimes you can just go
just this is what it is like you know
like if we just like to do it we like to
do it if we actually like to hang out we
like to hang out and if
i decide to fall in love with you then
that's my fault because you already told
me yeah
yeah you know what you i have fallen in
love with
i need it's actually the most
comfortable bra i've ever
owned and uh i i feel like people
we've said this out a million times so i
guess people know by now but in case you
didn't know like i didn't know i was
i didn't have a bra that that didn't fit
me yeah most women don't
yeah because you go to you know i'm not
going to say the name of the brands but
there's like big
brands that we all used to go to and
they don't really have a custom fit
they're just kind of like a generic
one-size-fits-all so have you ever had
like
the gap that was my problem i hate that
me too
and then also after a while my straps
would fall off and it was just a mess
but i thought oh that's just how bras
are
but they don't have to be that way with
third love you can find
the exact fitting bra for you and they
have so many different sizes
um you so you go online and you take a
quiz it takes you like 60 seconds text
60 seconds sexy sexy
and then it helps you identify your
breast size and shape there's so many
different
shapes i didn't know boobies could go so
many different ways
and then you find styles that fit your
body so they have a perfect fit promise
if you don't love it
every customer has 60 days to return it
returns and exchanges are free and easy
and then third love's team of expert fit
stylists are dedicated to helping you
find your actual perfect fit
and fit stylists are available to help
via chat or email and i like that their
returns
actually go if they have gently used
bras they'll go to women in need
which is awesome they're donated um and
then uh your bra
should have comfort and quality with
signature details like the memory foam
cups no slip straps scratch free brand
you know it's just gonna make sure it
fits your boobies
so third love knows there's a perfect
bra for everyone right now they're
offering our listeners 10
off your first order go to thirdlove.com
big mood now
to find your perfect fitting bra and get
10 off your first purchase
that's thirdlove.com big mood for 10 off
today
yes qriket titties and an unfitting bra
are unacceptable you know what else is
unacceptable
crooked ass teeth our friends at candid
can help your
crooked ass teeth get fixed in a very
short amount of time
usually less than a year and all from
home too from home yes you don't have to
go you don't have to worry about being
in a dentist every
week or every month or i don't i never i
mean i have perfect teeth naturally so i
don't
i don't know what i don't know what you
guys went through to fix your teeth
you could have teeth that look like that
yeah there you go candid clear liners
are comfortable removable and totally
invisible unlike those
ugly ass wire braces so you can
transform your smile without anyone
noticing plus your treatment is
prescribed and monitored remotely by a
licensed
licensed orthodontist who's an expert in
tooth movement
with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring
by the same orthodontist who created
your plan so you'll never have to wonder
how you're doing and you'll always know
the average candid treatment is just six
months you'll start seeing results way
before then
and it costs an average of less than 50
percent
than the major competitor invisalign
start straightening your teeth today
right now
all of our listeners can save 75 dollars
on candid starter kit
go to candidco.com mood and use code
mood
that's candidco.com mood and use code
mood to take advantage of this limited
time offer to save
seventy five dollars on your starter kit
co dot com slash mood
code mood mood moon y'all are good at
that
oh thank you yeah we're all
professionals we just do the same we get
the same
we have we've had the same sponsors for
a while so we and we do like our
sponsors so we kind of like
it just comes out naturally yeah yeah it
seems it seems like i don't have any
like weird sponsors you know like some
off-the-wall [ __ ]
i've done like car speakers but again
i've had to cut commercials before i the
one thing i hate doing especially
because
we were talking about radio i hate
cutting commercials
because it never feels like i'm
genuinely talking about something
because i haven't even seen the product
yet
like in some cases you know most of
these you guys are actually wearing the
products
at least yeah yeah y'all did that real
smooth like you like you're wearing it
or you've done this before i was like
wow that's nice
do you think that's so smart like all
advertisers should do that because when
they can
we can tell when someone's genuinely
talking about something
totally and like if you're talking about
car speaker and you're telling me like
and i've never even had trouble is ten
percent yeah there's
there's nothing worse than reading an ad
that somebody else wrote
thinking you talk that way and then
you're like i've never said yo
this is
no that's not happening yeah and then
you're doing this live too right
yeah yeah i was live um monday through
friday from 6 a.m till
10 a.m and yeah that is live like is
there any
like difference of time where they can
edit oh my god there's been so many
times
we've been talking and i've been like
can we just [ __ ] can we just do that
again like
i can't imagine not having that yeah you
get used to it
i don't know i i felt like i i have two
different people right so when i go on i
know
i see it and boom it's there and then i
do another i do another
show on the weekends called the basement
and that's um we have a lot of it's a
syndicated show it's a saturday night
hip-hop mix show
so we cut that before like we're not
we're not in the studio
cutting that live which i wish we did
because that would just be so lit um
because my co-host is really bomb uh dj
iraq
but when we when we do that we have
certain things we have to hit we have
certain points we got to cover so it's
like okay
we record it then they have to send it
off to get edited and then the editor
has to send it off to get approved so
that's a whole other process a little
bit more like this on the live show have
you ever [ __ ] up or like
i've said [ __ ] before oh man there's
my co-host has been in the game for like
20 something years and everybody runs
into those moments and for the most part
the biggest thing that you learn about
going live is not cussing that's so hard
i could never
not cussing so hard being able to take
your moment to process what you're gonna
say
avoid ums as much as possible the
hardest part where i'm like
what what are your tips to speak more
articulate yeah none of that i can't
feel like amazing at
any of that we cuss a lot
um oh i cuss a lot all the time but it's
a different person
you know you just put on your hat like
yeah your radio hat and you just don't
[ __ ] it up
i feel like that's what it is certain
topics would get me hot
that's like the triggers my co-host
would purposely do things to
you know incite a fight with me because
it makes for good radio
and i will call you out at one point we
were yelling at each other
but it's all in good spirit because we
know we're off the mic
i know exactly what he was doing but one
time i was like
if you don't shut the [ __ ] up i gotta
get lit
and we just pray that you don't get
recorded doing it yeah that's it that's
it
and when in doubt say the person's name
that you're talking to
if instead of um oh that's a good idea
okay i feel like so i've never
consciously tried to stop cussing
because i'm just like whatever
i don't have to yeah i don't there's no
way it's not necessary but i have tried
to constantly because
with the child you have to oh true so i
tried giving up for lent
once and that was the only lent fail
i've ever had i couldn't i just wasn't
the hot cheetos that you said back in
the day
it feels like everybody's lint give up
with hot cheetos oh and high school
cheetos
for me to see soda or hot cheetos or
candy yeah
chocolate yeah yeah for sure but yeah i
couldn't do that one but
um i have um i have consciously tried to
stop saying um and i noticed
it comes up at a higher frequency when i
care a lot about trying to get the exact
information across like when i really
prep and like
have all these notes and i want it to go
perfectly i'm like
wait um uh so she was born no uh she was
born in this
state i feel like um's are okay
occasionally because you're having a
conversation we're not doing a proper
interview right now so it's
like you flow a lot more freely yeah i
struggle flowing
in an entire sentence i end up stopping
myself
a lot and i don't know why i do it it's
all the drugs from your teenagers
i think they do have like some missed
like synapses some misconnections in the
brain
a little bit for some reason when the
mic is on i'm a little bit more there
when it's not on i'm like
i forget everything i'm super forgetful
how was your first day
on live radio i wanna know that
experience my co-host
doing the morning show was different
than doing the midday so i did the
traditional route you do overnights
weekends overnights midday's morning and
i did middays and morning
at the same time and each spot has a
different approach to it
so morning you're talking to normally
most of the people that are taking oh
it's okay you want to play footsies
you can just tell me i'll i'll take my
hills off for you
so so every everything is a little bit
different middays i'm talking about the
song oh yo the next song coming up is
by so and so tune in we got the gossip
at you know whatever is going on during
the time
the mornings is more of a podcast format
kind of free
speaking and you have to keep in mind
your target audience the first day i did
it i had no real morning show experience
and i was filling in the
the woman before me retired and she had
been in that seat for eight like 18
years
wow they hated
no real radio experience i was six
months into radio
i had only been doing radio for six
months and i got a morning show seat
that's awesome
how how was even that first six months
though like what was that experience
very different i was like this is cool i
didn't know how i felt about it it was
back where my
family was i thought it was dope though
was it live as well
most of it was pre-recorded okay and
then when i had time to get into the
flow of the rhythm
and then when i started doing the
mid-days you have to run aboard at the
same time and let me tell you
i was not good at it no definitely too
much for me
there's a lot going on so you see the
jocks in there they're doing
all these mics and things have to run
and [ __ ] misfires all the time so you're
doing that as you're entertaining people
yeah
so mid-days i didn't i wasn't there for
long and i don't think i was the best at
it to be completely honest it's not my
style i wasn't
deaf i wasn't the midday person so when
i sat in the seat for the first
time with my co-host he didn't even prep
me i had no show prep i had nothing he's
like we're going to go on the mic
he was like you're going to talk to me
and and him and i had already been
speaking for a while so it was
very easy he made it very comfortable
for me so my first
day i just never looked back
i think if you have someone that's
really professional it's almost like no
matter who you are they'll make sure you
look good still
yeah he filled in on all my gaps
everywhere everywhere i failed at he was
like i got you
yeah like an improv that's what they say
like you're only as good as your weakest
member so everyone should be lifting
each other and
support he pulled our weight and on the
technical side i've had to run the board
by myself
and running the board on a morning show
versus any other time slot is not easy
most
professional shows have producers they
have somebody that's running it so that
you don't mess up there's a lot of money
on the line you have advertisers you
know there's a lot on the line
oh i got left in there by myself and i
cried because there was the one day
everything went wrong the power went out
i couldn't figure out any of the i
i i cried and i had to call my co-host
it sounds like a nightmare
it isn't it was the most terrifying
experience i've ever had
in i was working my first time like as
an adult that was my first real job
yeah oh well as far as yeah being in an
office having happy things
i go show up at work and nothing uh
decided to work that day and i cried in
the studio
you know you went back and that's
amazing because if i had cried and been
under that much stress i probably would
have showed up the next day and i
told him that he is not allowed to leave
me and nobody left me in the studio by
myself ever again
it was okay i was like yo my strong suit
is not this i can talk
yeah do my tooth don't make it press the
buttons and there's a lot of buttons
yeah
yeah and there's a lot of stuff that you
have no control over you can press the
button for it to go and
an engineer has to come in and be like
oh no that's not working oh yeah
it sounds like a nightmare it was but it
sounds like a great
learning experience and look how much
stronger you came out of it
i still don't know how to work the board
i should have learned but i did it it's
like when you get assigned dishwashing
duty and so you break the dishes you're
like this isn't for me that's exactly
that's exactly where to wash the dishes
sorry
my boss at the time had to come in
because i wasn't to be trusted in there
by myself
she can't be crying on air she's like we
we can't have her in there the songs
aren't running but
you probably get way more listeners like
some people like do this girl's having a
breakdown yeah
101.2 the listeners in the morning they
they got a kick the ones that stuck
around got a kick out of me being on
there
and the ones that hated me there it was
yeah i could just imagine like the radio
cutting in and out of like you pressing
buttons
like some car commercial and then you
like end it early so it's like
a sound bite but i have no idea it was
bad i was off the air i cried i had to
call my gm in
it was it was a it was a [ __ ] show i was
a mess i'm definitely not qualified
to run the board i'm okay and i did
exactly that and he never left me in
there by myself
again they're like nah she's no that's
good
it was great yeah i never thought it was
like the first experience so it wasn't
like
oh the first time it was so smooth and
now they trust me with too much
responsibility
oh yeah they kept their expectations
real low with me i'll be completely
honest they were never blown away by
anything how long were you there
three years well two and a half years i
just quit
was there is there any reason that you
wanted to quit
there was a lot but for me
remember the am i doing what i'm
supposed to be doing am i in the right
place in life where do i want to be
we have a pandemic we had family we have
finances there was just so many factors
that came into play that
either you step up and do what you want
to do now or you sit in a position that
you regret
and i had to take advantage of the
opportunity and the time that was given
to me
i loved it there it was great they were
amazing i definitely didn't want to
leave
but it was the best decision for me in
this time because i
would probably be sitting 10 years from
now
in somewhere i don't want to be if i
wouldn't have walked away that's great
that's great yeah i'm all about
listening to your gut on that mm-hmm and
you're in
so many people don't like you know you
talk yourself into oh
logically like i have a secure position
here
and maybe my gut's telling me this isn't
for you but like
but like it makes so much sense or
whatever a paycheck or
a any residual income
is one of the biggest creative um
killers like creative
like creative you know what is the word
creativity echoes like creative
creativity
like two seconds ago and i can't even
say creativism
i didn't even notice it until you said
that i was like oh she
yeah i tend to make eye contact to
distract people when i'm [ __ ] up so
if i just look at you deeply that's
what's going on the words not coming out
of my head
but the consistent money was making me
go i'm too safe can i do this and that
was really the biggest problem i was
having i was like i can live a
completely different life
right now i can settle down i can look
towards having a child because for me i
wanted to take off a year of work
if i could take off a year of work do
that be in the home have my family be as
close as possible probably stay in the
valley
not move to the bay area and not move to
la
and i could do that in the job i was in
i could live that life but did i want
that life will i regret not pursuing it
while i still have the chance
so i had to make a decision and i wasn't
creative i felt completely blocked and
everything else i was doing nothing else
felt fulfilling and it wasn't even the
money it was just like okay i can pay my
rent but what am i doing i'm not happy
yeah that was the biggest thing i was
not happy and not creative at all there
was no hustle
yeah when you're a creative person and
you don't have that
that joy fill in your cup every day like
you really feel it
more than people that are just like hey
i'm just here to work and
get a paycheck and stuff yeah when
you're creative you're just like i
am going to die like yeah it's yours it
hurts your soul
where other people don't really feel
that right right i feel like i just want
to you know work and
just go home i envy those people a
little bit
oh yeah right i do i envy those people a
little bit because they're sure of
themselves
that's the goal to be sure of yourself
to do what you want to feel secure
right in your decisions yeah so for
those people that are going to work
they're very happy with what they do
and they get their paycheck every month
and they live the life that they want to
live there's nothing wrong with oh yeah
i'm not coming down on those people
i hate when people [ __ ] on them and they
were like uh you don't want to be an
entrepreneur no [ __ ] that's hard
it literally is not possible for
everyone to be there yes
even just logically like entrepreneurs
need workers so
yeah exactly you can't shame the people
that need those positions
but a lot of people would hear what
you're saying right now and be like whoa
you gave up
that like you could make money you're
talking like you're doing something cool
but and you would have been secure and
you gave it up because you weren't
feeling creative yeah and like and so i
was just trying to
get like trying to defend creative
installation
but also in making that decision i put
six months worth of rent on the side
able to pay all my bills invested
yeah you made it in a while yeah i mean
this wasn't a
oh my god i'm miserable i need to quit
my job yeah
it was like no credit score is correct
dental dental is all taken care of i
went to the doctor
he was smart cause a [ __ ] ain't gonna
have health insurance next month so
let's get all these things checked off
my rent i've always lived and my parents
gave me a lot of
financial insight and my grandma put me
up on game and they're like you can do
whatever you want as long as you have
six months worth of rent that's right
you can do anything you want your
anything at all you can go anywhere if
you have six months worth of money
yep your life can completely change you
have plenty of time to actually
transform or switch over to whatever
career six months is a good amount of
time to
get your feet wet into something and and
i think that's great
yeah we just had a finance episode the
last question was how much do you have
an emergency fund and it was six months
yeah yeah six months i got it i put that
to the side i worked on my credit that
was one of the things that i was doing i
made sure i had solid credit because you
know cash only gets you so far
right and when you don't have money
coming in you gotta have good credit for
the i mean you guys had a financial
absolutely right
you know what's up like if you don't
have a job you don't have credibility
and if you don't have good credit then
they're looking at you like what do you
got
yeah right like i have collateral to put
on the table right
so i had all my ducks in order and all
in a row and then i was like okay cool i
gave my month i did my time
i try to go out as gracefully as
possible and make sure that what's cool
next for nikki blades like what
does like fill your cup are you still
kind of like figure this out yeah
yeah i'm here this helps actually a lot
yeah this helps a lot i've been wanting
to come here the
the
myself into jk too i'm like how do i get
into all of these things i want to be on
everything
we're trying to get her to move here
okay guys yeah no i'm working on it
when tiff was like when tiff was on you
know when i came on jk news
and we had talked about big mood yeah i
was like
can i come on i really want to yeah i
was like because i ended up inviting her
and then she ends up going like
really you want me i'm like are you
doing like yeah absolutely we want
people yeah like i i don't think it's i
i think we felt the same way like
will she come on yeah yeah does she want
to come on i know when she
when she was like are you are you sure
i'm like wait are you sure
do you you want me as much as i want you
right like can we can we have a perfect
relationship
yeah i just wanna i just wanna hang out
with you guys this is no this is like
one of the perfect
transitions into what i wanna do is
hanging out with you guys hang out and
eat some food perhaps
i love actually nicki street eats is
really the passion project that we've
been talking about
connected and you're going to tell me
about how i can get some food yeah
i mean what maybe streets can go onto a
delivery service perhaps
uh currently door dash will bring your
food
right to your door it's just like in the
name and if you
want to eat from any restaurant you're
feeling we were talking about seafood
earlier
there's over i think 300 000 restaurants
is it on here it's not on here anymore
i know it by heart it's 300 000
restaurants that are one more plus or
more now maybe they added more
a lot of them are still open during the
pandemic so it's
a great way to support your local
restaurants if you don't want them to
you know go out of business because
they're losing a lot of that like
walk-in clientele you're like hey
deliver to my door
ordering is easy you just open up the
door dash app choose what you want to
eat and your food will be left safely
outside your door with a new contact
list delivery drop-off setting
you can support all all the all the
faves chipotle
[Laughter]
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of 15
or more when you download download
the doordash app and enter code big mood
that's five dollars off and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app on the app
store and enter the code
big mood don't forget that's code big
mood for five dollars off your first
order with
doordash and while you're waiting for
your food to arrive you can be playing
my favorite mobile game
that's right best fiends i i'm sure you
guys are annoyed of me talking about it
all the time because i genuinely love
this game
like insanely i've been playing it for
many years honestly i love this
this game because it is a puzzle game
and also the fact that you can play this
without wi-fi
or any type of service is my most
favorite thing about it because
sometimes
i live like in my new house there's
these weird like dead zones where
sometimes i don't get any service and
i'm just like
what do i do i don't want to kill all
your data how am i supposed to play this
on the toilet when there's no wi-fi yet
but you can with best fiends because you
don't need no wi-fi
best fiends is the binge-worthy mobile
puzzle game
with over 100 million downloads are you
good
with over 100 million downloads and
counting it's free to download and it
has
literally millions of five star reviews
on the apple app store and google play
more levels events and challenges are
added all the time
so even with seasons like they they keep
up with the season so they give you
new challenges the way that you get to
play this though is you collect these
little fiends
and each fiend has like a special power
and then you're using these powers like
you have to be strategic and how you use
them
so you can defeat the slugs and that's
what you're trying to do
with those slugs and then advancing the
levels and honestly like the graphics on
this game is like
really breathtaking well graphics i've
never seen
a an app game that actually has graphics
yeah they all look
shitty usually right yeah and that
that just adds to the the fun at least
for me i'm an aesthetic
kind of person aesthetic queen
so seriously once you download best
fiends boredom won't stand
a chance download best fiends free today
on the apple app store or google play
that's friends without the r
best fiends yes i love games wait so
what's
nikki's street eats oh you never
that's pretty much why tim and i are
friends oh [ __ ] cause we like to eat so
nikki street eats i started i want to
say about
five or six years ago right after i did
maxim so i did maxum magazine
did i tell you guys know that right so
that's why i was like
modeling something yeah yeah maxim is
huge
awesome i was awesome so they had the
hometown hottie competition yeah i
remember that where they named the top
10 hottest girls in america
i think yeah i was one of them
so if you haven't been watching this on
youtube you've just been listening
so it was named uh one of the top 10
hottest girls in america which was voted
and this is
thank you i got a title you can't call
me ugly
you can't call me ugly there's a vote
there's papers
it was a democracy yeah she was voted it
was voted but it was cool because during
that time maxim was highlighting
instagram that's kind of
how i got into the influencer world and
it was a lot to do with personality
from there one of the main things that i
did my intro video i like slid in
on a countertop in like superman
underwear yeah and i was eating
cereal and watching cartoons in my
submission video nice
from there i was obsessed with the
carl's jr commercials
yeah they had great commercials the
really sexy commercials and for
me i've always been a big eater i love
food i
grub i throw down like you could leave
me by myself i don't care i'm eating
everything like first date we're not
getting salad boo you better
bring your wallet nice yeah because we
are eating everything
so i never understood why there wasn't
anybody that looked like me
in those commercials i never understood
why there wasn't anybody that looked
like me in entertainment
and in general and especially in the
food lane and it was wide open this was
before chrissy teigen really stepped in
and took over
so at that time i wanted to do this
thing called nikki street eats and i was
showcasing the food trucks because this
is when the food truck industry was
really booming
so i did little short videos i did a
calendar i did all of those things and
then i got it and then tim stole your
idea
no no i was like
like tim and i connected because i love
like that's really what was getting me
into any type of work was the fact that
i had nikki street eats and i did those
things
and i just wanted to show that there
were more more women eat than don't eat
yeah and during that time it wasn't
something everybody spoke about so
freely like we do now and it's weird to
even say that oh my god
like i don't eat or i'm i'm still no i'm
not like that
times have changed a lot especially with
the mukbang
genre that got really big yeah those are
all [ __ ] hot girls eating hot girls
nasty
amounts of food i got so ashamed i was
always by the snack table
yeah always i got called the garbage can
because i would eat it
i would eat everything and i worked out
again yeah i loved it
so i didn't work out that was my life
that's all i did
so i but you know we had talked about
wanting to be a food critic it was a
model food quaker so like the two go
hand in hand with me i can't just eat
i mean we contradict each other really
because like it's supposed to be skinny
as far as industry standards so i got
into nikki streets i had a team and then
throughout
time that's been one of the one of the
projects that seems to be
very enticing for everybody but the
follow through has not
quite been there and i refuse to put out
whack [ __ ] when it comes to that and
that's been my baby for a long time so
nikki street eats is just my passion
project on the side
of my policy oh it's on instagram right
now at nikki street eats and i've been
doing that and referencing it as much as
possible
i did not know that i'm gonna yeah i got
a whole food page
but it's yeah that's something that i
step away from from time to time because
you know
building the team as you guys know
because you guys have this whole
production is
not easy to do and especially over years
yeah and i'm not the person that can
edit myself i'm not very good
at looking at my own videos and editing
them i will not do it i don't like
watching myself i don't
listen to any of my own work i don't
watch any of my own work except photo
shoots because i
i know that world but besides that i
really don't touch anything else and i
haven't found the proper team to make
that happen yet and every time i get
close
something happens my photograph my the
guy that was going to do all my editing
we worked together he got picked up by a
huge company
so he got taken away and good ones get
taken so every time there's been
something
um it got stopped and so i know it's
about timing and timing is everything
and i go back to it as much as possible
but
eventually i would like to have all of
that taken that's right
yeah what if you just got a contract
like with another
with like a network or something to have
something completely different i've had
i've we've done that before we've tried
a lot of it is frustrating and timing is
everything you know yeah
you know this industry timing is
everything people can love your idea you
can have full shows written out i have
seven shows of my own
put to the side ready for when the right
people come along
but i feel like a lot of guys keep
getting shows or like the most random
celebrity will get a show
and i'm like why does she get a show
it's really there's a bunch of people
that we don't see running stuff but
that's why you guys do this and that's
why we have other opportunities with
with social media so for me it's just
finding the right
time and with the opportunities again
the last three years has been spent
working for somebody else
yeah and i was feeling very styled like
i was stuck there was no food where i
was
there yeah you can only eat at the same
six places i live next to cows like
legit
i'm staring at cows when i leave my
house the options are
few and far between but when i worked in
the city so now i'm going to convince
you to move to vegas
there we go my family i family in vegas
and they want to come to vegas how do
you feel about that whole
max mass exodus out of california hawaii
left hawaii a long time ago and all
moved to vegas so vegas is the ninth
island
all of the locals all the locals all
over there house auntie
uncle cousins everybody that is
continuing to tell me to come and see
that are you hawaiian i
am oh my gosh i did hula and tahitian
dancing for like two
years yeah i'm hawaiian chinese filipino
that's amazing i'm
i'm filipino in white but we talked
about that
yeah before we got really drunk on our
episode i feel like
yeah i must have the drunkness must have
taken away the i did not catch that
you're hawaiian that's so cool yeah
i don't speak in my accent but if you
ever you see my mom and dad i post them
on my instagram you're like oh wow
that is your dad what island yeah uh
oahu
oh nice but then i grew up in the
central valley next to some cows for
real like two stoplights
house all of it that's where i grew up
or like because you
used to go visit before this pandemic
yeah did you ever feel like you wanted
to live there
big part of me i would go back at like
three months at a time
but if you want more than the island
life
you you get pretty stuck so i can only
do a certain amount of time and then i
have to leave
i many islanders in the in northern
california yeah
i was blown away because i went to a
tahitian festival there once and i was
like whoa
yeah there's a lot of amazing halals in
um
yeah yeah everybody hawaii if you're
familiar
a lot of people don't know there's a
huge you know homeless problem
drugs are a big issue domestic violence
then you have just the cost of living is
extremely high education is not normally
priority
so there's a lot of systems that i mean
there's a lot of things that are broken
out there
and our family wanted to take me off of
the rock
raise me where they can monitor me and
make sure that i had the best
opportunities possible because
i mean i know a lot of my family isn't
in the best positions and it is the
lifestyle that you live out there it's
completely different i would be a
different person if i still live in
norway
but i love it like i love my family i
love that life that they live
i want to go back occasionally but to
live there and work
like i don't know what i would do right
like i yeah i don't know
when i'm there i'm just like this is
just for relaxing there's no
there's no like you got to get up and go
and yeah do something with yourself
there
yeah it's just a relaxing a lot of beach
towns are like that yeah a lot of my
friends are in the nightlife industry
so that's dope they get you know
hospitality and all that they get their
money but it's
it's a dope dope lifestyle you wake up
you're eating what you want
you're going where you want you go to
the beach you can hike everybody's
mentality is a little bit different
first off and the designer clothes and
[ __ ] out there because it's the taxes
are different
a lot of people shop out there it it's
amazing but if you have other goals and
ambitions you have to split your time
regardless
you can be successful there's a lot of
educated people there's a lot
to grow but you can't do all of that
there you have to leave at some point
and i am not ready to
settle down in hawaii because i will get
i will end up pregnant
i'm getting pregnant okay so las vegas
she's trying to convince everyone to
move to vegas yeah we've been
trying for like a year or two years but
now it's seeing me like more people are
jumping
i'm supposed to go actually one of my
best friends lives in vegas
oh hell yeah yeah she's been trying to
convince me too she's like your rent is
ridiculous
i know i know especially in norcal what
about you guys are you going to leave
not me no i'm not living i'm doing stuck
you're a cali girl for
probably for life but at least a solid
five years because
son because my son is in a new school
now i don't want to move him again
that's very nice because i know some
parents don't give a [ __ ] and they just
be yeah
they just how was my parents i didn't
give you just move constantly
i wanted to live in california i was so
happy when i got to live here
like when i'm from texas texas yeah i'm
a texas girl
um but i see the problems i see the
homeless issue i see the taxes and the
government
the of count the state of california
california's [ __ ] like i see
all of it but i still feel like i love
it so much like there's something i'm
not even from here but i feel like i
love this city so much like even
people like just driving through people
that don't look like me it's not my
neighborhood i just feel so much love
for california and i don't know
why or where that came from and it just
feels sad for me to think about
leaving like i don't want to yeah i
wanted to get i wanted to get better
yeah i don't want to just you're not
done with it and i don't make enough
money to where
leaving uh will affect me tax wise like
i'm not in a tax bracket that
that it would really affect me so i'm
like well i get why other people are
leaving but
for me there's not enough reason i just
[ __ ] love i love it i love la i love
it
again timing yeah because i i feel like
two years ago we were thinking about it
we weren't quite quite ready but now
like i think it's on that
that time especially if y'all's crypto
hits yeah
we were talking we were we were talking
about we were talking about that last
time i saw him i was like okay so i have
one solid coin what else are you doing
like one point yeah i was like i got one
one coin is expensive what do you mean
i have the whole coin yeah i have a coin
plus a
yeah where did you get it i got it when
i was at uh 7 000 which was really easy
okay it's it's low but it's still high
um but you're still up i think right
yeah technically yeah we're on a 60-day
run right now being over ten thousand
i'm one of those that wakes up checks
their coin checks the news
he's gotta wait wait he's gonna wait i
was
we've talked about because joe was
didn't he lose hella money in crypto
honestly honestly like that was a very
contentious
argument that we had in our relationship
so we probably shouldn't get into it but
yeah he sunk so much money into it and i
watched him and like i get that it's
probably great investment like if you
know the right ones like someone like
steve
he's done so much research where he
knows where to put it when to buy and
all that stuff
but like we would fight so much over
that i was just like you put so much
goddamn and not even diversifying just
just dumped it all
i was just like all right i know because
when we brought it up
somebody said crypto and i had both of
them in the room at the same time and
you just see one go
they see steve and then he looks at me
and i'm like i know i'm still with you
i was like i guess we're not going to
talk about this sensitive subject but
i was like i got i got one he's like
keep it i said good that's what i'm
doing
you're like talking over joey yeah joe's
like i bought the wrong one
yeah yeah he's angry where i'm like are
we good it's all like it's a lunch show
it's a lunch break and then the whole
joke with joe i mean have you
you know the whole joke yeah i i've seen
it and i'm like
okay it's funny whatever i don't know
everybody else has decided they took it
and ran with it but you gotta explain
for the people
okay that for the people that don't know
they have tried to
put joe and i in a relationship because
i think that he is happy
because they're both single people right
that's what our
fan base does like our audience yeah
like if there's
two single people right they're gonna be
together so like all the guy the single
males that we've had on our show it's
like oh i'm with the i'm going through
them
i definitely want to [ __ ] them for sure
and i'm just like
okay this is funny for entertainment
we'll go with it yeah yeah yeah
and the whole thing on no chaser is that
i'm not looking and i make that very
clear i'm not interested i'm not looking
same
it's not you it's it's me i don't want
it you could be the most amazing person
not now like you'll
stop trying yeah so when we were having
a conversation about it like you said
they just ship whoever's there like i
apparently have been in multiple
relationships with every guest yeah yeah
on the show even within the married
people like oh no
yeah oh yeah they're like tiffany wants
to have sex with barb yeah yeah
you see that yeah so badly so
we're just like you know characters in a
movie yeah so everybody's like moving
their little pieces however they want
so so the joke is is that him and i
really would never
it's the dream would be to live in a
duplex like you have one side i have one
side and we just hang out like we want
nothing else to do with each other
besides like
hey i think your mushrooms are pretty
cool do you want to go ride a bike today
like that's the extent of it it's like
being cousins
yeah but everybody but everybody just
runs with it so i'm like
[ __ ] it i'll take this let's go and i'm
pretty sure i make him feel extremely
i uncomfortable i don't think that's
possible for me he's very haven't you
noticed he's really quiet when i
when i do my little stuff on the show he
doesn't talk much to me he just kind of
sits there
and he just sits there cause i'd be like
right and he's like he doesn't know how
to respond how to respond
he's probably thinking like i really
don't want you but i guess we're doing
this right now
no i think i highly doubt that i think
he just he's put on the spot
yeah yeah he's like i don't know he
doesn't know how to banter like
he's never a middle person he's either
all or nothing so like
with his anger all or none with his
romance all
or not like so if so he doesn't know how
to play like in the middle that he's
just like
that's what makes it great because
everybody else has shipped it
then i'm like cool i'm just going to
really make you feel uncomfortable
every time i'm on and you've become my
talking point and when you're looking
for things to talk about you go
back to what you know right do you know
that so i'm the manager of the channel
so i review all of the videos
you see me getting on i watch so i
basically
i have to watch all the videos before
they come out um like just as a final
production step
whatever so i'm watching them that i'm
laughing and honestly i'm just like
do you see his face he's just like
okay guys because he just
yeah he doesn't really say anything so
i'm like cool everybody else has ran
with it so i was like
give me the ball i'm going for the
touchdown because they'll get tired of
it funny like selling
points click on this video because
nikki's flirting with
jojo you know and then you watch you're
like i don't think he likes yeah
he just looks so uncomfortable i'm like
see you have to consent people
just can't force yourself on everybody
force people together
right i think i think you know married
people married people and
um fans that watch have the same thing
in common where we're like two single
people make them kiss
our last guest our last guest that we
had on there
yeah yeah they created a ship name and
i'm like you're saying
yeah i created it acting like everyone
else
yeah that's fun how do you deal with it
cassica oh god i just get really
uncomfortable
and i'm like what do i do now i don't
know uh
i'm just like stopping i'm just like
stop
no don't like legacy especially like not
necessarily castle but like sometimes
like they'll ship me with the most
random
person or like i guess it makes sense
but then i'm like y'all really don't
know that i really don't even like that
person
so it's awkward i think if you actually
were to get together we'd be like whoa
that was yeah
you're like wait a minute we were just
like kiss
yeah yeah have you ever had somebody on
the show that you
thought could possibly be someone you
were interested in
and never we've only had like yeah so i
haven't had enough money like single
mail
on any of your shows ah oh i've never
been in the same room
but i would have considered dating some
people that have
been on a show around us maybe not our
show
someone actually someone actually
shipped it in the comments a long time
ago but i'm not going to say who it
did they ship it did you see it and
secretly go i was like yeah but only one
person thinks that
and you're getting thumbs did you thumbs
it up no was it your car wait maybe i
did thumbs up i can't remember
it wasn't my comment but i was just like
it was really random too because it
wasn't connected like
like we weren't in a video together and
no one said our names together
but it's just the fact that like in some
way we're connected through like you
guys have several degrees
yeah and now you guys have homework and
figure it out several degrees and said
oh they should that's
why i was like having a crush on
somebody sounds fun
i'm not a real question because i don't
i honestly don't even know him but i was
just like oh he's cute
like we live vicariously married and
fans we're just like
vicariously like we're not gonna be in
that crush phase ever again so
like just watching other people yeah
that makes sense i don't know if i can
date an entertainer though so
yeah that makes sense i want to get into
the crush phase again i want to have a
crush on somebody
i'm still not even ready for that i mean
i'm not saying i'm ready yeah
i didn't i didn't say i was ready for it
no i'm looking forward to it the next
time it happens
let us know so we can watch it's always
so disappointing though after
like if it doesn't work out it's so
goddamn disappointing i'm gonna call you
i'll be like
well speaking of calling us call us any
time this hour flew by
did you do that like it made it we feel
like we want to talk forever
i know we need like multiple episodes
find nikki on all of her platforms go to
instagram
go to nikki street check me on twitch
i try to throw blades in as much [ __ ] as
possible
a woman with puns i love it
and then also of course rate of 5 stars
on itunes it helps us out a lot and also
uh thumbs this video up so it helps with
the algorithm if you're watching on
youtube and
leave us a comment let us know like what
you've been up to
what you want to ask nikki for the next
time she comes on yeah
and we'll see you later bye bye thank
you